one of the big story lines as the 2019
season approaches will 49ers quarterback
Jimmy Garoppolo begin to earn that huge
contract that he received after just a
handful of games with the 49ers remember
49ers traded for him in the 2017 season
he started the last five games of the
season he played well the 49ers won
those games and then they had to decide
franchise tag or long-term contract they
went with the long term contract twenty
seven and a half million per year over
five years this year the question is
will he start earning that contract last
year he had the torn ACL suffered in
week three after he decided to cut back
inside as he was heading toward the
sidelines in the second half of an
eventual loss to the Chiefs lost his ACL
and the process lost the rest of his
season this year
another big money payment for Jimmy
Garoppolo for the second year that
five-year contract after this year
though that's when it becomes much more
easy for the 49ers to move on if they
want to a total cap charge of 4.2
million if they would decide to cut or
trade him following the completion of
the 2019 season the way the 49ers
structured their contracts they build in
until April 1 to make a decision before
injury guarantee becomes full guarantee
so they'll have that window of
opportunity assuming that Jimmy
Garoppolo is healthy enough to pass a
physical after the end of this season to
maybe move on from Garoppolo before that
guarantee vests on April 1 and ties
their hands for another season the
question is will they do that and that
question is going to hinge on what he
does this year and some of the other
factors beyond how he performs you've
got coach Kyle Shanahan and GM John
Lynch entering the third year of
six-year deals fully guaranteed with no
offset language well as you get closer
and closer to the end of those contracts
the buyout gets cheaper and cheaper and
if ownership isn't happy with the
direction of the team they decide to
move on so maybe the thing that the
49ers would need to do after this season
in order to get year four and maybe year
five in the hopes of getting your six
for both Shanahan and Lynch win enough
games and if it doesn't work bail out on
Garoppolo and say we can bring in a
different quarterback who can turn this
around who can
to this operation before the 49ers yet
again hire a new coach and a new GM so
the focal point is Garoppolo will he
earn that contract and if he doesn't
what will the 49ers do about it there
could be a new quarterback in San
Francisco as soon as 2020 much of it
depends on what Garoppolo achieves or
doesn't achieve in 2019
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports